How much of the math did you actually understand? Who is the best out of the class in applying the maths and
Are you better Sodoku now?
What was the last part of the question? Are you better Sodoku now?
What's that? are you better at sudoku now am I what? better at Sodoku now? Thank you
I can't even hear so how can I be good at sudoko
No, no, no we had one day. We all thought. Oh, yeah
We should really be doing crosswords
So we brought in like the quick quick crossword there were five of us, and it took us five days
And we still didn't finish it
So no, we're really bad at all of it, and I didn't understand any of the maths. Did you? Don't say you did.
That opens up a whole can of trouble yeah, that's it why I remember where would they be had this specialized
It was trying to describe this wonderful machine alan turing
Bletchley Park almost always talli nice face
It's just how many thousands of times we broaden you had the all this expert, and it was flying and be just
Listening and NBC this panic the eyes of everybody was looking at it like this is this is impossible
Is that feeling I haven't had since school being in maths. Just like you sort of feel that you've died and
there's no way to
Concentrate at all it was that and I'm desperately fighting cuz he was such a nice man you go
This is really interesting I should be paying attention and I couldn't
[there's] a great broad romance the road to the philosophy of maths and physics. Which is dramatized these days
Which is which is tangible hopefully because otherwise
There's no point in explaining
It all sharing it with an audience
and I think there are hugely exciting things that on a base level everyone can understand the idea of coding the idea of
Programming the idea that what we use is language can be turned into something
Universal and could be used in a machine here China Russia. You know you're wherever and and
Those things excite me. You know the fact that my eyelashes carbon in it from a star excites me. I don't necessarily
understand
everything about how to make an eyelash
But it's the broad brushstrokes are very appealing and I you know as far as the machine goes the machine the bomb
Christopher and ours, but the bomb in reality at Bletchley park. That was the moment
thought right now this I I'm
This is very hard and the guy the guy standing in front can you explain it to me and he just looked at me and went
Right so what we have here?
And you knew it was not just me not just a stupid actor but also the fact that every other person
Isn't necessarily a pure math expert a mechanical engineer or a combination of the two. These are incredibly complex machines
breaking down incredibly complex problems a great high level and sorry High pace and
High volume and you know as I understood a little bit about it
I did understand it, but I understood a lot about the enigma machine the absolute coding machine and
But yeah, if you put it algorithm in front of me [now]
I even a quadratic equation would have this press conference going far too long no shit
you